hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the criticisms that gets made
against utilitarianism as a moral and
political theory is that in some respect
it's unjust it goes against our
conceptions
however we happen to have arrived at
them of justice so there would be a
disjunction between the as mill says the
just or the moral and the expedient and
the useful this is quite a common
misunderstanding in his view of how
utilitarianism particularly the kind of
utilitarianism that he himself is
advocating and he which he takes Jeremy
Bentham the originator of utilitarianism
in the Western tradition to have also
been articulating the basic idea in his
response is to say that justice is
really a way in which we think about
what has the most utility and we give it
a particular emphasis one that allows us
to engage you know the state or other
ways of sanctioning involved in in
punishing to protect something that's of
great value but what's of great value in
this case the utility that is the
benefits maximized for as much as we can
across the the system of all and the
harms minimized as much as possible
again for the aggregate of human beings
within the community so the question is
does utilitarianism conflict with
justice and Mill is trying to say that
no it really doesn't but we have to see
why that's the case so he tells us a few
things one is that the idea of justice
itself involves two things he says a
rule of conduct how we ought to behave
how we ought to decide things how we
ought to say apportion goods and a
sentiment which sanctions the rule so
notice that he's saying that justice
doesn't just include a rule it's not
just a decision
procedure it's also something that we
feel it's a sentiment a moral sentiment
in fact not just a pure emotional
response but something that has a kind
of rationale to it and that we find
rooted in our own psyches sanctioning he
says the rule he says this this first
the rule must be supposed common to all
mankind and it intended for their good
the other is a desire that punishment
may be suffered by those who infringe
the rule and mill is a very you know
typical enlightened man of the 19th
century but he still thinks that there
is some need for punishment in this in
this in order to have justice so he
tells us that there is an involved also
the conception of some definite person
who suffers whose rights and we're going
to talk about rights in another
discussion are violated and he says the
sentiment of justice appears to me to be
the animal desire to repel or retaliate
some hurt or damage that's that's what's
involved in this sentiment and then he
says how does this play out and and
again if we think about this in
utilitarian ways this makes a lot of
sense
it's not just about oneself he talks
about enlightened self-interest but we
also feel a sense of sympathy for others
who are hurt or damaged by the actions
or the the in actions of other people so
he says those who were united to my
sympathy you know and and that that
could be so widened as to include all
persons so that you know injustice
anywhere is of concern to us right that
is what he thinks is involved in the
very notion of justice now is this
compatible with utilitarianism Mill says
yes and as a matter of fact if you want
justice
to be fully realized you need to in fact
be a utilitarian this is a rather
controversial position to take in his
own time and indeed even in our own
because it seems that there could be
some things that the utilitarians would
be for that might be unjust so mill then
attempts to provide some sort of
argument for why it is that justice
itself realizes a greater utility and
that's why in fact we we should
recognize and and involve and include
justice within utilitarianism so he
talks first about violation of rights
he's got some interesting examples here
that I think are worth thinking about he
says that when we say that that
something is a person's right we mean
they have a valid claim on society to
protect them in the possession of it
either by the force of law or by that of
Education and opinion and then he says a
person for example has a right to what
he can earn in fair professional
competition why because society ought
not to allow any other person to hinder
him from endeavouring to earn in that
matter as much as he can so if you're a
labourer society should not try to keep
you from earning something from your
labor nor should other people interfere
with that and say shut you out and make
it impossible for you to engage in it
now notice the next thing that he says
he doesn't have a right to 300 pounds a
year even though he may happen to be
earning it that was that one at one time
a lot of money because society is not
called on to provide that each other in
that sum so what do we have a right to
it's going to depend on how it's
specified we have legal rights we have
moral rights much of what we nowadays
call human rights are hopefully
enshrined in some sort of law but
they're definitely what mill is calling
a moral right so that that's quite quite
important
now when of
violation of rights occurs what takes
place if we think about this as
utilitarians there is definitely a
trade-off in pleasures or advantages and
pains and disadvantages between the
person who's you know rights are
infringed obviously there's some sort of
hurt or damage to them but for you have
somebody else benefits from it you know
maybe if we think about you know
something like the right of eminent
domain right we say that it's okay for
us to take people's property because you
know the government could use it for it
for something that's not the only
justification of it and if that really
was the only justification Mill would
say you're not entitled to to have
eminent domain why because overall when
rights are violated
there is a lowered utility across the
board why would that be the case Mill
says that this is because we can no
longer count on our own rights not being
violated when somebody else's rights are
being violated with impunity we lose
security and security itself is part of
a good as a matter of fact if you think
about how utilitarians calculates
pleasures and pains one of the key
components of it is how likely it is
that we're able to enjoy and continue to
enjoy that pleasure so he goes on and he
says the interest involved is the out of
security to everyone's feelings the most
vital of all interests all other earthly
benefits are needed by one person not
needed by another and many of them can
if necessary be cheerfully forgone
security no human being can possibly do
without if we depend on if we depend for
all our immunity from evil and for the
whole value of all and every good beyond
the passing moment if we cannot rely
upon society the social fabric the the
who were associated with not to violate
our rights we have a dramatic lowering
of utility and not just us everybody
involved including perhaps even the
person who is violating the rights
because they can't count on other people
not doing the same thing to them so what
does this mean this means that if we
consider justice in in terms of
maintaining or respecting rights we do
so because of the higher utility in
maintaining or respecting rights justice
and utilitarianism turn out not only to
be compatible but to require each other
he also talks about equality and
impartiality he says this is very
important to people as well right what
happens if we show partiality let's say
we engage you know in a society where
there's lots of corruption it's great
for the people who are able to benefit
from it who can bribe their way into
whatever they want how does everyone
else feel about it they think it sucks
this is this is garbage and so there's
there's an overall negative utility to
that but what's going to be particularly
important here is where this
impartiality comes from so he says this
is an obligation of justice right it's a
necessary condition of the fulfillment
of other obligations of justice and he
says you know you could try to derive it
from the notion that everybody should
get what they deserve if everybody is
more or less the same they all deserve
more or less the same thing so if
somebody is not say a criminal or a
chronic abuser of the system then they
deserve for the system to look out for
them just as much as it does for anybody
else we should then if you're part of
that system you know making judgments
well then you should make those
judgments impartial you should treat
equal cases equally right not you know
give your neighbor a break and punish
the people who live down down in a
different part of town
or make the bait and make a judgement
based on gender or race or religion or
any of the other things that that we
think divide us Mill says well that's
kind of true but there's really a
something else that we derive equality
and impartiality from the greatest
happiness principle which is intrinsic
to utilitarianism he tells us this great
moral duty rests on a deeper foundation
it's it's an emanation from the first
principle of morals what is that it is
involved in the very meaning of utility
or the greatest happiness principle he
says this is the the doctrine that
unless one person's happiness is
supposed equal in degree is counted for
exactly as much as another's this is
this is intrinsic to utilitarianism
you're supposed to be impartial you're
supposed to treat equal cases equally
that's what the whole moral theory
requires so again it turns out in this
case that not only is utilitarianism not
incompatible with justice it is going to
lead to justice there's one last thing
that needs to be observed this is an
important thing that I didn't put on the
board but which mill is going to talk
about he well actually there's there's
there's two things one is that he's
going to say that what we mean by by
justice he says is certain social
utilities which are vastly more
important and therefore more absolute
and imperative than any others as a
class that is why we want to have not
just the rule of conduct but this
sentiment that sanctions them that is
why we don't want to back off on
insisting that justice be done and
injustice be punished because if we were
to do so we would actually violate the
greatest happiness principle he does
point out that there are going to be
some tough cases there will be some
conditions in which we have to really
think to figure
what the just thing is and in those
cases we do need to apply the greatest
happiness principle we need to think
about what is for the benefit of the
larger number and perhaps if it's going
to happen to the harm of the lesser
number but only when that's that's
absolutely required so he says that
there there may be some social duties
that are so important as to override any
of the general maximums of justice so
for example to save a life it may not
only be allowable but a duty to steal or
take by force the necessary food or
medicine but that doesn't mean that
taking food or medicine by force thereby
becomes okay it just means that in that
circumstance because of the way the
greatest happiness principle is going to
apply it is allowable in that
circumstance it is it is required he
also taxed funny example here about
kidnapping a doctor right kidnapping and
compelling to officiate the only
qualified medical practitioner this is
the stuff that that you know interesting
movies are made of aren't they but these
exceptional cases really just prove
according to mill the rule of the
greatest happiness principle so as it
turns out justice and utility are
entirely compatible with each other
you